bien nous en manger ailleurs son vivant
à l'alimentation du futur passera par
les insectes
à moins qu'on devienne tous vegan ou
qu'on soit tous morts bref les insectes
c'est plein de protéines de vitamines
mais l'idée d'en manger n'a absolument
rien de nouveau
[Musique]
en se plongeant dans les archives la
première fois qu'on a parlé de manger
des insectes c'était en 1959
des membres de la rtf imaginer la
gastronomie du futur à base d'algues un
peu mais d'insectes surtout un document
muet doublé période soit on va dire
aujourd'hui à régner sur canapé
sandwichs aux chenilles et tourte aux
larves de tan tan je vais prendre la
même chose que monsieur est aujourd'hui
eh bien ce n'est pas vraiment dans nos
habitudes au mieux en france on trouve
des insectes apéritif au poivre au curry
à la tomate mais ça existait déjà dans
une épicerie fine à paris en 1971
vous avez des chenilles sont dignes et
légèrement salée vous avez également des
sauterelles n'est pas pour l'apéritif
plutôt pour le dessert ce sont les
fournit en eau ni chocolat
en fait l'homme mange des insectes
depuis toujours c'est resté dans
certaines cultures où on peut manger des
punaises dos au même titre qu'un bon
bifteck
mais en france c'est plutôt un élément
de curiosités comme la télé des années
90 les aimer son vivant un secret c'est
bon c'est sucré c'est bon petit goût de
noisette
la télé c'est en rire mais dans cette
même émission un chercheur nous
expliquait aussi pourquoi croquer des
insectes et bien non merci
la répulsion et purement psychologiques
et culturels on nous a pris depuis tout
petit les insectes c'est sale alors
qu'en fait les insectes sont beaucoup
plus propres que des mots ou des huîtres
qui vont être les filtres de la mer en
europe la vente d'insectes comestibles
et encadrée depuis le 1er janvier 2018
ça a permis à des marques de développer
leurs insectes apéro à certains
restaurants de proposer des burgers à
base de steak d'insectes mais de là à
devenir une alternative à la viande on
attend toujours
[Musique]